what up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it is the great area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman who is
currently battling with the majestic
creatures in the sea the 300 pound
whales is just what he thinks thank you
sir what a great intro it's great
it's great me guys today I've got a cold
so if I cough and I splutter please just
bear with me however today we have a
great show for you today we are talking
about simping
but
before we even get started tell them if
you have watched two or more of our
videos and you have not subscribed then
we have what pal beef what do we have
beef exactly so you better get doing
that right now over to you pal okay guys
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first is that we have two
clips channels that is just pearly clips
and pearl daily both of those are linked
in the description so make sure you go
subscribe to both
um they both have two different like
types of editors on the channel so you
just get a little bit different types of
Clips on both channels
um on top of that guys we have four
membership tiers the first you get to be
a part of our live chat the second you
get our behind the scenes Vlogs and our
Discord the second you get to connect
with me on social media and the fourth
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month some people use this for help on
YouTube or just questions about the show
um on top of that guys we are really
close to seven hundred thousand close to
700k wow uh which is crazy because I
started this show in um I believe March
of eight months ago March of 2020 it was
um the end of February so it's February
27th about 2021. so we and I had 20 000
subscribers so it's kind of bad how in a
year I was there at that time right you
were you were there second second or
third episode I was there from the jump
yeah which is mad guys start a channel
you never know your life can change in a
year this is it um
um also guys follow the pregame show if
you want to come on the show and DM them
um and then also I lost my Instagram I
was almost to 85 000 subscribers or
followers and they took it away from me
they canceled you I know I know but I'm
starting over I'm trying to get to 5 000
so go follow my Instagram it's just
pearly things one and also go follow me
on Tick Tock they took away my first
second third and fourth Tick Tock but
they can't get rid of you girl can't get
rid of them they can't get ready I'm
back follow just pearly things uh dot
five and just probably think six right
um good today we have a great show like
I said but we're not here alone pill do
you know what I mean we've got some
people here in the studio with us we got
some guests we got some guests we got
some folks
um so what I'm gonna do is we're gonna
go around and folks are gonna tell us
your name your age relationship status
and a fun fact about you we will start
with Mr sunglasses chilling in the
corner all right uh uh hi guys uh my
name is Muhammad uh I'm 29 married
been married for about five years
and been in the country for about 10 to
11 years now
what's a fun fact about you the fun fact
about me
I think uh
I have a cheeky smile cheeky smile
cheeky smile okay let's go back there
lady in the jumpsuit hey I'm better
known as of the India
um I'm 24 years old
um a fun fact about me are you single
are you oh I must think oh I'm I'm
taking baby but
um a fun fact about me oh I don't know
what's the fun fact about me
um I'm gonna say that you know I'm a I'm
a I'm a whole personality I've got loads
of different personalities so I'm into
the so come into a little garage I'm a
little bit muddling a bit about
everything in it so I'm like you know
fair enough it's bad shape okay on the
sofa in the middle
my name is Sarah I'm 21. don't take my
name
I'm single as a pringle
fun fact about me
um
I don't know see I don't know yourself
you gotta know yourself no there's a lot
of fun facts about me I just don't know
like what do you oh I do tattoos that's
it there you go
all right uh back there miss Von Dutch
hello hello my name is Jennifer you are
drawing me out with the age thing but
I'm 30. I'm single because
guys ain't
you know what I'm saying fun fact about
me I have 23 tattoos
wow yeah
are you and you're single yeah because
guys ain't are you gonna get 24. of
course okay yeah well if you pay I'll
get your name
what if you pay I'll get your name
[Music]
what if what if could I get my logo on
it
you gotta pay and tap
[Laughter]
I'm 21 and I sing and I'm single I'm
single okay cool next my friend in the
corner
hey uh my name is Malik I guess fun fact
about me uh I run my own poetry show
actually poetry singing
um spoken word called underground bars
doing quite well
nice okay
um
folks today we are going to be talking
about simping okay
um so as we get started I'm gonna ask a
question to everybody
do you guys know what a simp actually is
I've been one
okay go for it yeah I've been one female
simp okay go for it myself pick up my
thing so basically
in my experience as a simp that does way
too much for someone that would never do
the same for them
but I love him though so you're citizen
what is what is two what is too much
like what did you essentially anything
when you're a simp you essentially
shouldn't be doing anything for that
person
so anything you do is too much but you
do as much as to think people might say
what is that your man
no but I love him no I was just
wondering like what is too much like
what were you doing okay in my example
okay he had a girlfriend but
you had a guy who already had a
girlfriend yeah but so what are you
doing with him
I said a chick Yeah so basically you're
a side chick okay so okay I didn't know
he had a girlfriend yeah but when you
found out he had a girlfriend you stayed
with him right yeah because that's my
baby so you got side chick energy
don't have a girl however him especially
because I didn't find out he had a goal
for about what was it like two three
weeks
energy so if I meet you in person and
it's good energy I will link you every
day so it's like you know like when
you're in love island or Big Brother
house two weeks is like two months so
essentially them two weeks was my two
months she's saying she loves a thrill
I love the fruit so in my head I was
like yeah this is my money and your men
after two weeks how long has it been now
how long like how long until you cut it
off oh no no
are you still with him I mean it sounds
like you he said she still loves him so
so
it's going on here when did I meet him
so you're saying let me just yeah it's
been about a year and a half one more
time wait hold on hold on a year are you
so okay so let me just so after two
three weeks you found out he has a
girlfriend yeah and instead of saying
you know what I'm gonna cut my losses
and get out no no you were like let me
just ride this till I die so she was not
listening to the advice
does it a girlfriend now oh hell no no
no no no no no so the girlfriend has no
idea bro
by the way about it you're a scientist
you don't personally feel like she
probably knows but she don't know it's
me so it's fine
how hot
there's no way this is an average
looking I'll just show you Josh
yeah
I'm gonna grade him one to ten is
anybody has anybody else been a simp
is someone who caters to anything and
everything a woman wants and actually
showers her with love and attention and
doesn't necessarily get it back
[Music]
you shower her with everything and you
love her and you want her and you show
all this kind of stuff but she's kind of
like yeah so you kind of simp without
okay so you've never you're telling me
you've never been a simp for a woman
I've never been a Sim but uh I can uh I
can tell that I've been always
someone who's who's really caring and
someone who's as a man right if I think
if you if you if you were raised in the
rice household and you see your parents
or your father
taking care of their wives
and they raised you to be
they raised you to grow up to become a
gentleman
I think there's okay let's just like
okay I'm gonna step back and explain to
you okay let's just say at school yeah
you have this this kid a very smart kid
you know
but people don't call Smart Kids smart
kids they call them weirdos or like
something else different names because
they're smart right right so uh what I
don't understand is what if a man is
just a gentleman but end up like end up
quoting a Sim
have you ever as a man felt like you
were given more to a woman we always
then then she was given to you we we as
a man to this day we always give more
than modern women give that's how I feel
okay you know because as a man as a
provider you know I think but you're
married though aren't you I am married
and uh and the reason why I say that is
because women expect more
from us than we do expect from them
you know women expect more from from men
to do than we as a man expect women to
to give us right so uh either way
whether you're a simple gentleman or a
gangster
whatever you call yourself you still as
a man
give you more
okay so why is it so why is the Sim so
narrow down to the gender though when it
comes to men that is my big question
because
I don't know many female samps to be
fair
the girls that like usually say they're
Sims it's like all they offer is [ __ ]
thank you all right
no 90 of girls it's like what else do
you bring me you know why ninety percent
go ahead no no no no do you know why
because goals are socially accepted to
be Sims because you're a girl so when a
girl does too much
so right so say if a guy likes me and
he's going over the top I'm airing him
he's still messaging me I don't give him
attention he's buying me stuff you're
now a simp it's embarrassing right now
say if a guy don't text me back I still
message him like I don't know much about
I'm still doing stuff for him your goal
so it's a bit more now in society people
are gonna judge a girl less for being a
Sim than a boy no but no no I understand
what you
mean girls are just expect no it's true
because to kind of Chase off the boys
but boys are not expected to chase
but as a woman what would you prefer
would you prefer I want guys for chasing
me okay so hang on okay that's a very
interesting um thing so if you want guys
to a certain extent right this is where
I'm gonna go so if you want a guy to
chase you yeah if a guy's constantly
chasing you and showing that he's always
about you you're gonna get bored like
that right because the guy I used to
tattoo I would probably see him two
three times a week and he'd probably
ring me every day but when I ring him he
don't ring back but you like that though
but if he Rings me let me know but you
like that though right like like what
like but like but like but like but you
like that but like if he Rings me and I
don't call back there's an issue
no but the thing is women like that
Chase they like guys like to chase no no
but hang on if a guy is chasing you down
too much hit this no exactly yeah too
much yeah it is it depends it depends
how I'm responding if I'm actively
responding to you in a way that suggests
you can still chat to me
cool if I'm airing out your thing stop
what you're doing immediately stop what
you're doing
it's not if I air you two one too many
times it's a actually just stop chatting
guys why don't you just say you're not
interested guys this is why because
let me just say to the camera this is
why nice guys finish last no let me like
let me help explain to you why okay you
cannot do that let me explain why
aggression that means let me explain why
right you say why don't you just cut off
the guy that's chasing you but you don't
really want the attention because I
promise you the guy that I want is not
giving me enough attention that I don't
need yours your attention is feeding my
ego however when my man replies yeah go
away okay so so let me just so you're
gonna use the other guys for attention
listen and then chase after the guy you
don't like because how would you feel if
you were in their shoes because I'm a
hypocrite because you started you
started you started the podcast saying
that men ain't [ __ ] but you you kind of
are being ain't [ __ ] to men yep I'm a
hypocrite do you know what it is
I feel like if I'm intentionally airing
your message or not responding to you
you know what it is if a guy is airing
my messages and I choose to double
triple message him I know what it is and
I'm choosing to be that person if you're
messaging me and I air you you message
me again you messing again and I owe you
but I enjoy the attention you do give me
when you're messaging me picking me up
but I'm choosing to air you you know
what it is this is why this is why you
know what it is I go this is why I tell
men just focus on yourself
guys [ __ ] yourself because you will
never ever ever be able to understand
the psychology of a woman no because for
as a guy right does that make sense to
us it does does that make sense but
because as a man if we say we want X Y
and Z that means we want X Y and Z right
go for it yeah I mean a woman will say
they want X Y and Z but if you give them
X Y and Z they're like no I don't know
if I want that it's like but you said
you wanted it I can't like that's not me
though personally if you give me exactly
what I want your mama now
[Music]
he chases me and I let him stay there no
hang on you're actually with a man
that's not your man you're a side chick
you just said earlier you're a side
chick no not anymore but you were a side
chick you used to be a savior you know
why though you know what I didn't go in
saying I want to be next if I knew from
the beginning I'd rather I'd rather be
no no I'd rather be I mean I'd rather be
single yeah then than knowing that I'm a
friend let me learn with benefit yeah
right oh oh I'm buying this girl while
the boyfriend already I wonder let me
laugh the man no the man we don't do
that like we don't we don't Batman we
don't mind girls that has boyfriend
already let me know but for women it's
fine for them for every man let me speak
let me speak no no finish finish bro but
for
for for girls it's fine for them to know
them well in the head that this guy that
they're sleeping with are not their man
right but you wouldn't do that listen if
as men we know if our if a woman that
we're sleeping with yeah is getting
penis from somewhere else
it's just sex don't get me wrong I feel
like there's always an end goal to end
up with someone but sometimes you know
in the time there's someone you're mad
sexually attracted to and they can stay
around until you find whatever you need
to find don't get me wrong if I met the
guy and you had a girlfriend in the jump
I would never entertained it sounds like
a little bit
I mean come on
I have a serious question though so have
you ever asked him like what his
girlfriend has that you don't
no no no no no
I'm just thinking like if I was gonna if
I couldn't tell you if I was gonna be a
side chick should I compete if you're
gonna do it anyway if you're gonna do it
anyway do you know what it is Ling oh
she's good she's good looking right oh
yeah all right so oh my God
let me ask a question
if if he um broke up with his girlfriend
impossible not with me no I'm sorry if
he broke up with his girlfriend and said
I would just want to be impossible why
why is that impossible because he
cheated with me no but I'm saying no but
no but if he said I'm gonna break up
with my girlfriend and I'm gonna be with
you just you and it's possible would you
be with him impossible is that I know
that's you wouldn't be here listen come
away
because you said you love this guy so
you would be with him right
am I a bit of an idiot for this guy
absolutely however
I'm a chosen idiot as in I choose to be
there you're a chosen idiot I feel like
the main chick is worse than the side
chick do you know why because the side
chick knows she's a side chick she knows
what her world is she knows the main
chick is thinking that's my man oh
that's I love him no we both yeah but
that but the manager gets the commitment
yeah I suppose
yeah but he ain't leaving her for you
exactly
I'm sorry what you say oh saying he
ain't leaving her for you no that's fine
so either way she is the chosen one do
you know what I mean there's no choice
of one in this situation everybody's
what you require in a relationship he's
just playing both of you he's telling
that you're my girl he's telling you I
like
everybody
but she might she never you never know
she might know throughout all of human
history the top guys have had multiple
women they've always had a main chick in
the concubines so so in this situation
no no offense you're the concubine from
what I know of the situation she be
getting DMS from other girls so she semi
knows however I feel like there's a
difference between say if I'm with a man
that's I'm with Drake and then all of a
sudden Drake's not with you
no let's say I'm officially with Drake
yeah but he's not weird and then all of
a sudden someone richer and more power
comes along am I necessarily going to
leave Drake just because something
better come because so yeah only for
money
okay
you know what the difference is one
second one second one second that
actually leads me to something that
actually was going to ask
um who's do you know what monkey
branching is I've never heard of that
okay so monkey branching is when you're
in a relationship right
but you kind of you've got a there's a
branch somewhere else
you might go somewhere else if you're in
a relationship but you you're thinking
over there so when you said that you
were you're with Drake
Etc but there's a man or if someone more
rich and more successful comes along
would you go I think
and correct me if I'm wrong ladies I
think women monkey brunch no more so
than Mendy no no oh men do it in the
darkness
do you not say if I've got something
good stable good money cheats me good
now meet someone I think the connection
is bad or the money's but whatever
something's better
but if I leave what I've got that might
collapse and I've got nothing I tell you
why because you don't have pergamines
right yeah so I poke I mean hypergamy is
that women want to date are constantly
trying to date up no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait women are
constantly trying to date up they're
trying to get trying to get the best
deal that they can get men men will get
a deal and be like you know what I'm
actually quite happy with this and hang
on let me finish men will get a deal
they will get a woman who's a six out of
ten
she takes all the boxes and they will
Coast for the rest of their life wait
wait wait
so women are always looking for that
level up right which is why which is why
if I was to ask all of you women here
right now the types of men that you want
you would probably list a man in the top
20 of men right but if you're listening
to Madison the top 20 of men what's
gonna happen is what if a man comes up
who's in the top 15 percent whoever man
that comes in the top ten percent
no no no but listen
you just show me you just showed me his
picture you just saw him though he's
tough twenty percent yeah we don't have
the same time but but does it not go
down to like back for example there's a
traditional way of a man needing to
provide for a woman and you know I'm
saying oppositions in life even through
traditional culture does that not work
fools to you when you exactly no I mean
because when he's talking about women
trying to get the highest level
I'm trying to go like from hair to hair
career-wise money-wise home family for
example so exactly that's what you boys
I'll tell you why you take Kim
Kardashian for for an example right Kim
Kardashian started out with Ray J right
yeah then she went to Reggie Miller he
was an NFL football player right and
then there was an I think there was
another NFL football player right and
then she found Kanye but she went down
but Kanye was the Pinnacle of Kim
Kardashian's
um the man that she could find right so
what she
she started to breed with because in her
in her heart and her mind she was like
this is Top This is top level so she's
she's now got four children for Kanye
right and then wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait let's wait wait yeah
she's got four children for Kanye right
she felt like she found the Pinnacle
he's a billionaire she's a
multi-millionaire yeah she felt like
that was her level after that she
divorced Kanye where's she gone to
do you know what that's true Pete
Davidson right and do you know why
because after having four children
right so after so after Kanye West from
here on out it's downhill for Kim
Kardashian because she's got four
children
let's not cap though as girls like how
of course you want a person of course
wait of course you want to reproduce
with the best guy you can no yeah
the way I see it is that as girls we
always look for the best because
we want that like we don't I don't know
I'm speaking from personal experience
anyways and
if I meet a guy that's got everything I
want I'm not cheating on him I'm not
looking at other guys I'm not worried
you know what I mean but if you see if
you're dating someone and you see like
things that are missing in that person
automatically you guys gonna Wonder guys
they can have a 10 10 goal everything
lay down for them whatever and they'll
still cheat
I have a question for you would you
rather have a guy that had everything
you wanted but he cheated from time to
time but you were the main chick or a
guy let's say let's say you're five deal
breakers he has three three of the five
let's tell you five things you want
here's three
I'm not gonna lie but he doesn't cheat
I feel like I'm taking the the cheat off
because let me tell you one thing yeah
that's very true
most girls would most girls would yeah
only because I can't give that guy that
has those what like what I would give to
someone who has everything I need would
you kind of look the other way I'd be
like I didn't see it
you know what it is
in my head I like to say it out loud I
would take the free but if he cheated
subtly and didn't embarrass me yeah
if there were no public embarrassment
and he cheated very subtly yeah
like of course
do you know what it is it's not a public
thing me and my man as a woman we
already go through menstrual cycle going
to work having to look good and it's not
even just looking good for men some
people do that personally I do I love
fashion I just love to feel good Within
Myself in it but being a woman is a lot
yeah I have to say life is good life is
easy life is no life is easy when we're
skinny people looking pretty that's what
I would say like as a young woman as a
Young Man life is hard
ER
yeah
100 100 that's a goal I feel like as
long as you're pretty
that's all you need to do thank you
as a man
we can hear each other we're speaking
over each other let's not let's not do
that as a man if you're not successful
top tier you need to be multiple things
multiple as a woman if you're just
pretty that can just run that can run
you don't need this you don't need to be
a woman
obviously don't get me wrong I say that
the reason why you're actually correct
is because a man that's got a man who is
successful right a man who is a
multi-millionaire had to go through
Blood Sweat and Tears and hard work
consistently to become a millionaire you
can be 22 and pretty and and a Instagram
model and that man can go into your DMs
and say look and I'm in Dubai and I've
got a yacht right I'll fly you over and
that he can have 12 women on his yacht
yeah right who are dancing and having a
great time and those women are literally
really on on benefits in the UK right
but that man has had to toil and work
and Blood Sweat and Tears and women are
trying to say women you you don't
understand you live life on Easy Street
you know you don't understand you live
like men if you find a successful man
trust me that man has had to go through
the hell to become successful you could
you can actually be next to a successful
man and not have done much
but my point is
as a man as you or me
that
that part of your time it's not going to
be forever exactly we settle my fair
enough we settled can I add something
and then uh like from my own experience
I came to this country when I was
younger right from where from Senegal
okay uh I did I've did a lot of stuff
right I've I've did crazy stuff but when
it was time for me to get married I went
back home with Senegal I went back to
Senegal yeah I found the right woman for
me because I knew what I saw from what I
saw in this country there's no chance
for the women in this country for the
women in this country there was no you
wouldn't marry a woman no country no oh
there's there's one percent chance right
okay because I'm not saying every woman
that I meet in the city on Friday night
or Saturday night all the same yeah
we man we we look forward to that
settlement okay and for us a settlement
is getting married finding the right
woman and having children and having
children yeah and settle yes right yeah
for for women their beauty the older you
get it it goes down it goes down yeah
yeah and as it goes down it's harder for
you to settle yes yeah yes it's harder
for you to settle it's time if she's
she's on a big time now the other thing
is but the thing is at the peak time is
when you should be trying to settle
exactly and that's the thing where a lot
of women of this they don't realize they
don't realize
they want to do City Girl stuff and then
when they get to 30. oh oh my God like
what the hell am I doing woman
I did want to ask you bro
um did you feel like you were simping
for girls in London which is why you had
to go to Senegal no
um no the reason the reason the reason
why I went back is because it's because
one it's because one I didn't I I I
don't trust the girls I see here raising
my kids
because I have seen women
I've seen girls sniffing out like in
front of the kids
are different I don't think you can't
find a wife in this country but it's
about the odds it's about the names so
if you're in this country it'll be at
odds you might have to go through 50
girls to find one that you could
potentially marry I feel like in your
country because the culture is different
you probably have to only go through
five girls to find yeah but I think it's
when we're talking about SIM PIN right
yeah the thing is with women in the
western world and women in the Western
World they seem like they want guys to
sim do you know wait wait they want guys
to simp for them okay so what happens is
when a man simps for a woman right it
puts him in the feminine and it puts a
woman in her masculine yeah and so what
what happens is is that the man starts
to be a woman and a woman starts to be a
man and so what happened and and so I'm
just saying and so what happens is is
that the the Dynamics of the
relationship get skewed and so women
while they may lack because women
generally lack attention you're women
you lack attention right however too
much attention from a simp you ain't
gonna respect
himself just think of the guys that you
guys have liked the most I mean were
they really simping for you
do you know a man only you can only you
only feel like the woman is taken to
man's role if the man is not providing
and doing the masculine being the
masculine
because a woman will automatically go
into a feminine energy as soon as she
finds that alpha male whatever you want
to call it
why would men provide traditionally when
they don't get traditional women exactly
but like like how many how many of us
are 22 year old virgins on here
you were saying about women like back
from his country want meant to sit for
them I think the difference is because
of the cultural difference there's no
questions
let me land right you see in this
country because of the culture and the
way women will get showered on women
like I can go to a club and just get
into a club and be on a man's table like
that yeah
so let me land so let me land is that is
I owe you absolutely nothing as a man
who doesn't know you of course so what
happens is the simp culture within the
Western world has become a norm yeah so
men will say okay cool and this is why I
speak to men men I'm gonna speak to you
right because if you are out here with a
lot of money you may have a lot of money
stop giving pretty women yeah stop
giving pretty women attention because
what happens is you will lose your
resources you will lose your money you
will lose your time and what will happen
is they will take your time effort
resources all the things that you built
up and they'll be on to the next time
they'll be sleeping with the guy
the difference is now when you go out
and you can spend a bag and buy a bottle
you're that guy now no but do you know
what it is
I could be um
guys guys
okay this is this is a warning stop you
can't be over talking the host it's
ruining the show the chat is picking up
on it you cannot be over talking I could
be a multi-millionaire right but if I
don't know you I have no obligation to
be spending hundreds thousands on you
right the problem is in this generation
when we're talking about simping there
are guys that are multi-millionaires or
maybe not even multi they just got a
little bit of money and what they feel
like doing and it's for me is like this
shows men do not know how to get women
without resources right they feel like
their resources can get exactly women
right and a lot of the time it can
because women love money women like
shiny definitely right but if men
understand if you learn to focus on
yourself and understand how to get women
without resources when you have the
resources you understand that those
resources regardless of whether you have
them or not don't it doesn't matter you
can still get women but what's happened
in this Society a man will have a watch
on his hand right we'll have a chain on
his neck yeah right he'll be at the club
will buy multiple bottles and he thinks
okay cool I'm gonna get some been true
I'm gonna tell you bro stop doing that
because the bottom line is those women
that you're trying to attract do not
give a damn about you yeah but then
maybe you don't give a job that's what
I'm trying to say if I've got a Fortune
of say like say I've got 50 right now
say I blew one rack on girls in the club
that doesn't make a dent in what I have
but you look like that you look like the
guy that's spending money so just
because you because you've just spent
enough to make you look like the guy but
not enough to Dent like your value your
financial but that's what I'm saying
that's the culture today that you it has
to be a cup to it there has to be a cup
to how much you spend on the this random
girl in the club to make you look like
the man but not the simp but the thing
is let me let me come on I have a
question for the girls if you really
like a guy do you does it matter how
much he spends on you like you if you
really if you if you really really like
a guy coffee date
no I believe that um when I like a guy I
just I care about his presence
um how he treats me how he talks to me
these things obviously as a girl you do
like the final things in life or whatnot
but it's not what matters the most for
me personally anyways money is easy if
you have if I have a million pound in
the bank and I give you a thousand pound
that's easy if I have 50 pound in my
account and I give you 20 that means
more but this is the problem though
people think because you have money or
that guy you're not that guy because you
have money anyone can make money the
thing is you're not making that the way
you carry yourself
it's got nothing to do with money
because you can go and spend a thousand
pound on a female but the way you carry
yourself makes you that Guide You
Because unless you can respect you even
more by how you present yourself and
that is because you can go to a chicken
shop date whatever chicken shop get her
chicken and you mention chicken and
mention a word they're called respect
and the thing is is that if a woman
respects you doesn't matter how much
money you have in fact it doesn't matter
how much money you don't have we've all
been with broke guys here if she
respects you as a man because you show
that you are a man you don't have to
simp your money don't mean anything okay
so can I just say something please yeah
go on bro uh like like for for some guys
eh simple to them is not simping it's
fishing right so uh let's say I see this
girl I want to get her right but I know
she's into money she's into going you
know buying her flashy things and
spending money on her that's that's
what's gonna get me to be with her or to
sleep with her right so for me I
wouldn't worry about
all the money that I'm spending or
everything that I'm doing for her in the
long run I just see the bigger picture
can I say something yeah get get her
into bed right oh so uh so so for men
some for some men simping is not simply
so so wait a minute
so what you're saying is that she's a
prostitute no no yeah
I don't know what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying what I see is to get her
into bed right about that money yeah
hang on wait so what you're saying is
you spend money on a woman yeah to get
her into bed is that not prostitution
[Music]
because you want something from her no
no let me get it no you know the
difference one at a time let him speak
let me get to a point if I know I if I
know you are you are more likely to be
impressed if I pull up on your on your
driveway with a bench right right I'll
go and rent that bench to pull out
to come together yeah but the thing is
no no but let me get to the point Sorry
women like flashy things right if I know
if I go if I go out yeah if I pop two
barrels three barrels or if I go up if I
go out with a bench I'm definitely going
home with a go then then I'm [ __ ] I'm
doing it yeah but let me tell you
something but that's an investment I
just feel like as if you if you really
like the guy it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
that's true in my 20s I'm 41. yeah but
in my 20s when I was going out I could
go out without a bins true and come back
you know what but you know why why
because I knew how to talk to women
because
and the thing is the problem now is the
problem now is guys don't understand how
to interact with wimp sorry no I think
I've got a cold guys don't know interact
with women oh hang on
so their money
someone knows me I think today can I say
something about you I think today of
women expect more I don't think it's the
fact that guys don't know how to speak
to women expect more wait like I know I
know certain goals that if a guy is nice
they come up to them they've got a nice
approach they've got a good energy and
they're not taking them Shard they're
not going
um
I agree with you women expect more and
they offer less we offer less than ever
but you know what I think it is that's
how women are though yeah do you know
what I don't know I mean like you've got
to be like that you gotta expect more
because you got you know you know what
you want from a guy and you have to as a
guy if a guy comes into your life and
he's trying to get to know you and you
have a certain expectation of that guy
actually doesn't reach that expectation
I didn't mean like offer less in in
terms of like compared to him I'm saying
like in all of human history yeah that's
like women bring less to the table
nowadays in terms
because anyone could be pretty you could
go and get plastic surgery and be a
[ __ ] pretty [ __ ] you know what I
mean yeah but for me
that's true but as a woman comes down to
like women and men provide different
things so like as a woman you provide I
don't know obviously everyone's got
their own mindsets but men provide like
they are providers that's where woman
they like they cook they look after the
children
how many women really how many women
really cook and clear it's automated now
no there is I mean
you know what I think the differences
never gonna go cook for you she's gonna
keep for you she's not gonna take care
of the kids she's not gonna do anything
that you look for in a woman but if you
go for a respectful woman a woman that's
been raised right in a family her family
has taught her good manners and
everything you're gonna get everything
that you want but there's not as many of
those that's true that's true but that's
because of society nowadays
the average age of first marriage is 31
in the UK though
you're right it's 27 28 it's like 35 in
Ireland like it's in the west it's an
epidemic basically but everyone in
America how many bodies does a girl have
by 31 35 28 and I'm saying like people
used to marry men used to know they
could provide for a girl and get a young
virgin they can't get that anymore do
you know why I think women need to kind
of have a higher standard than men
because you see if I'm a girl and I meet
a guy and my standards the subpar I
sleep with him doesn't work out happens
again happens again when my body count
gets to a certain level I'm seen as a
hoe I'm seeing this you can't watch that
but a guy could have double triple my
body count and it doesn't devalue
himself
we have to have a higher standard
because if we don't and we act like when
I say well guys can do it that's not
getting me no by any point I'm still at
home but whatever wouldn't it make more
sense to ask those guys what it was but
guys
I'm saying like like yeah like ask the
men what they want and try to be more of
what they want because guys this this is
my point like I said like he said when a
girl wants to bend a guy will say he'll
go rent a bins this is what guys love
the chase guys love this guys that
aren't ready to settle down love
guys they aren't actually looking to
settle down they love the chase guys
they're actually looking for something
serious you see the differences I talked
to men like that like I've talked to men
like successful attractive men like
where I'm looking to match make them
yeah and they're not really into the
game if they're if they're looking for a
wife but the key is a lot of times like
we date guys our age they're not looking
for a wife
but also ladies
you like men with sexual experience no I
don't know
what I'm saying
so let me let me let me ask you a very
honest question yeah
would you date a virgin yeah yeah yeah
you would date a virgin so Amanda
doesn't he doesn't know your body he
doesn't know how to give you an orgasm
there's no hard to have sex
most guys already don't know how to give
an orgasm I need to say that for one but
the question is do you want to do you
want this hang on I don't want it
do you want your man to please you of
course okay so to please you he needs to
have experience do you know why I say no
happiness ladies calm the hell down like
seriously calm down you're too good with
the questions what I'm trying to say is
a man if you want a man to please you
he's going to have to have sexual
experience he's
saying oh yeah calm yourself
okay he's going to have to have sexual
experience okay so to have sex
experience and to learn how to please
you he's gonna have to know his way
around a woman's body if he doesn't know
his way around a woman's body you're
going to go for the man who's slanging
Dick X Y and Z and knows how to please
you not really me personally
I'm Gonna Let You Go first you even talk
too much so go ahead then then you then
you then you okay so go ahead so me
personally
um I think I saw a virgin you never know
wonder you never know you never know
personally so I'm not gonna enjoy them
can I ask you a question question so is
it attractive to you if a guy he's
bringing you to his room and you have to
tell him what to do is that or is it
attractive when he just knows what to do
but sis imagine if he no no no questions
so is it attractive like you're on a
date with a guy it goes well whatever
however long it takes you he brings you
home back to his place and he's like oh
[ __ ] what do I do
and he's like how do I how does this
work is is that attractive to you you
know what I'm a very dominant woman okay
my thumb would not put me off me off
okay so so you're gonna tell him other
positions you're gonna tell them
everything
would you say the best sex you've ever
had was with a guy with little
experience almost a good experience
[Music]
because it's like how do I know what no
unless I've really gone into a deal you
can usually tell you can you wait wait
can you usually you can usually tell
based on how attractive he is of other
girls like him
okay okay and that and that in that
sense yeah you're right yes I'm more
attracted to that okay
just fine that's normal that makes sense
okay okay you could go and then and then
you two will go
why did it take so long to just admit
something that's so big no because it's
like what if it's basically no but the
thing is it's basic you want a guy that
knows what he's doing you don't want a
guy who doesn't know what he's doing you
don't want a guy who's like oh he said
okay to touch on me
no because that's a virgin you know it
is
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you
want a guy that knows what he's doing so
when so when I'm when I'm asking it well
when we're asking these questions why
why cap why
because I don't want to be masculine
anymore so therefore oh sorry I want
someone that is experienced because I'm
tired of being masculine of course you
want someone to take control I feel like
naturally I'd I don't know about every
other woman I'm not gonna quote for them
but I've had to cook for my younger
siblings and all them different type of
things you know I'm trying to say and I
had to take my own so you feel like
you're scared for yes yes and you don't
like it no no okay okay well I feel like
the this generation initiates all of
that no and and I agree you're that's
normal most girls don't want to date
virgins but why do we have to jump
through hoops to get to this answer
you know what I've never been faced with
it so I'd be like if I was I think I'd
be a bit more open-minded about it but
you know what I'm saying it's like you
prefer wait wait you prefer men with
experience we all do of course we all do
that but I think that's with everyone
but you might not always get that so you
can't be shallow minded okay okay you
can you can go next and you go then you
go okay has nothing to do with her
experience don't get me wrong if you've
got someone that's the extreme so like
you are saying mad shy I don't want to
touch you I feel that's an extreme
example that's not virgins because I've
slept with virgins I've been a virgin
and that's not been the case yeah you
mean when you were younger
exactly but let me explain now let me
land though let me like let me
personally
no because I hate arrogant guys and I
hate guys that can't be like I've been
chopped things like I know what I'm
doing no every single individual body is
different so what you did on her her and
her has nothing to do with what you do
with me see me personally I can't have
sex with you if I don't like you if I
don't have an emotional connection so
that's step one let me ask you something
I ask you a question really quick really
quick the guy that that you love is he
arrogant
um he is arrogant a little bit no let me
laugh because arrogant no his arrogant
has nothing to do with his sexual
performance he says arrogant you said
you don't let arrogant guys but your
guys no I don't like guys no I don't
like guys just focus on yourself
one second one second but you have to
understand from the guy's point of view
this is confusing because the guy no
wait wait the guy that you're breaking
all of your rules for I imagine you're
not normally a side
chicks
I imagine you're not normally a side
chick yes or no of course okay so this
is the guy you're breaking your rules so
let me learn wait so it's confusing to
men when you say you don't like arrogant
guys but the guy that you're breaking
all of your rules for and you've been
with for a year and a half and three
weeks in you found out he had a
girlfriend is arrogant based on your own
words I said I don't like guys who are
arrogant when it comes to sexual
experience your contradiction
let me land because you just keep
talking over me
and yeah any point listen I've openly
said I've opened said that I'm a
hypocrite don't get me wrong however
when I say I don't like guys that are
arrogant so we should listen to you
though no no no
I have some point though no listen no
listen I don't like guys that are
arrogant just entertainment just
entertaining today
so when I got so when a guy comes and
said oh I've got nine inches well I know
I've chopped bad girls that's a
completely your size and your experience
like your sexual experience is
completely original sexual experience
Jennifer guys it's completely all right
Jennifer
he does nothing special nothing
spectacular it's all about the shape
it's all about the fit to his thing to
my thing and it's all about this it's
all about the sexual attraction it has
nothing to do with what he does because
I can't sit here and says he does
anything out of the ordinary that I've
seen guys go more out of the ordinary
and it just doesn't bang
you just said
what it's about okay okay she does it
it's about shape your shape okay do you
get it please don't give me more details
you guys don't get it wait then
yes I told you
I told you it's about it it's
simple because when you have a mad
connection with someone you understand
that we can't listen to you right now no
but do you undone but do you understand
that I feel like you was a hoe back in
the day
okay okay
this is what I'm saying when it comes to
sexual experience for me personally it's
not about the size it's not about what
you do it's literally about the shape
how your
pieces fit to my pieces that's what
makes it special for me and if I feel
like I have an emotional connection with
you that's it okay okay
guys guys
that's rubbish okay go ahead go ahead go
ahead go ahead your turn um would you
date a virgin for me personally I feel
like the cons of the inner version is
that there's no X's no [ __ ] no
nothing that you know comes with baggage
basically wait that's a coin that is a
pro I mean sorry a pro
um but the cons of it could be that
you're dating the sky
this might not be as amazing can I touch
your face but everyone everyone was once
a virgin so yeah that doesn't got to say
that he can't learn the way you would
like to be but you'd have to teach him
right okay you would have to see I mean
are you happy are you okay with teaching
a man I mean yeah and I said no just be
real everyone's
but you kind of know what you're getting
yourself into right
right okay so obviously
the best but then there's guys that
actually have maybe a lot no but I'm
asking you a question like would you
prefer would you prefer to teach a man
let me let's make it a number so would
you would you date a guy with zero
bodies or a guy with say 30 bodies
I would prefer the zero bodies but
but obviously 30 let's say he's older
than you how you said you're 21 yeah so
let's say 30 bodies by he's 35 yeah yeah
35. what's that that's not bad yeah yeah
so so you'd be so which one would you
pick
don't know
to be fair I would I I'm quite
open-minded with both no no they're the
exact same one has one has sexual
experience one you have to teach who you
picking
I feel like I would just like the fact
that a virgin hasn't kind of has no bags
you pick virgin okay you pick virgin
okay I guess next okay what about you me
I'm not gonna lie
it doesn't matter how many bodies you
got as a man men are very they like to
experience a lot of things in life so if
you're looking for a virgin good luck in
it no but not for real so you're looking
for the guy that's not a virgin no I'm
looking for a guy that can treat me good
dinner that can give me what I mean
because you need experience to do that
right yeah so they're the guys I'm not
going for a bird I never said I would go
forever okay no I'm asking you guys guys
are the exact same wanna sexual
experience one doesn't who you picking
I'm picking the one with sexual
experience thank you I don't have time
to teach numbers
sorry so we can we can teach each other
on new things but I'm not right
the basics okay the basics everyone
knows
because you know what I'll go back what
do you mean
but virgins watch porn
no but you know what though coordinate
is not even close to sexual experience
my point is they see something and know
something
no because every every woman's hoo-ha is
different of course that's what I try if
you if you look if you if you look into
corn you're gonna see a woman with like
you know perfect who had a perfect but
then when you see a woman like a normal
woman A working woman every day you know
she's doing her thing you look at her
and it's not even close to what you see
on the corn and you're like hmm I don't
know if I want to do this you know but
then you know what I'm saying you got my
point is the Virgin knows something they
don't know nothing because they're
virgins being corn let me tell you
something
that is watching something and doing an
experience it's two different things
well I could I can watch the NBA but
that doesn't mean I know how to play
basketball but you're gonna understand
okay you know
I'll use my own experience I was 16 I
had watched corn at 16. I lost my
virginity at 16. when it came to
photographing my virginity I was nervous
as hell of course I don't know what the
hell I was I was like oh my God she's
coming and uh where's the condoms but I
had all of that going I like yeah but
wait wait what I'm trying to say is no
matter how much corn you've watched
being thrown into the situation is a
totally different thing so it doesn't
matter how much coins you watch well my
point is you're acting like a virgin
don't know uh
personally when I lost my virginity
I'm not gonna write you I was so
embarrassed and I it was so different
from what I'd seen that I was completely
turned off so there was nothing nothing
happened nothing continued because
actually to be honest I was like no this
isn't this isn't quite for me but then
that also lets you know what you what
you like actually want to have during
sex like the persons like what they're
like their body hygiene all these things
you don't even take into account smells
you've never smoked before right you
don't understand these things until you
actually go to do it and if anyone has
been on a corn set they'll tell you it
stinks but you don't see that through
the screen you can't smell through the
screen so they don't always think see
baby you got color because you respected
your time not everyone's like you you
know yeah
no but I'm saying have you been in a
concert of course not so how would you
know oh you're talking about chords
you just mean Jen nice okay oh
well I'm just yeah I was just saying
that like I haven't been on a concert
but from my experience it's like no you
you don't realize what you're getting
into until you do it and as a man it's
it's so foreign to you that unless your
partner someone who's like really
engaging with you and open to
communication and actually is just happy
for this first experience to be open it
doesn't have to be good but just open
that's completely different
and what are women attracted to how many
times do girls say we're attracted to
confidence how is a guy gonna have
confidence if he has no idea what he's
doing yeah but it's a film confidence
there's a difference between being like
in the intermediate not known like
absolutely anything and just knowing a
little bit enough to kind of get you
started I feel like he's virgins in this
like box to say they don't know nothing
at all okay I'm not saying they're going
to be the greatest I'm going to have the
highest amount of education on the fat
but they're gonna know something I just
I just don't know if you've really
interacted with virgins recently because
I like I've gone to do you know what a
pickup artist boot camp is
so it's like basically men will pay
thousands of dollars to learn how to get
laid one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year it's very it's very hard for men to
get sex and you know talking to some of
these guys like a lot of them are kind
of awkward a lot of them are shy it's
not like a guy that's charismatic funny
like most of them can't even get you
into bed how the hell are they gonna
have confidence when they get you there
that's the awful lot that's the extreme
example no it's not it's that extreme
but this is the thing like it's not
extreme if men can't have sex they will
so that's on a more niche market of men
I feel like most most men are not that
nervous
you know why she thinks that pill
because you're dealing with the top 20
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so what so what happens is
right the top you've been dealing with
the top 20 of men all of your life
eighty percent of men you don't even
know exist yeah 80 of men that you walk
in you go Starbucks you walk down the
street yeah they're they're doing the um
I don't know the uh the stacking the
shelves in
whatever it was right the top 20 of men
you've been dealing with all your life
well 80 of men you've been dealing with
So when you say men are x y and said
you're talking about yeah let me ask you
let me ask you guys a question what
percent of men do you think are over six
foot
give us a percentage give us a
percentage
okay so how tall does a guy have to be
he has to be six two at least six at
least six foot in it at least I'm not
sure you know what I mean because I
can't be with a guy that shorter than me
just makes me feel like I'm the man
what if he's Jack because I'm I'm six
foot and I don't mind if a guy is pretty
muscular it's okay yeah you can handle
in it like I feel like if a guy is
shorter and he's muscular like I don't
care no I can't do that like a 510 guy
muscular guy no yeah I've gone for a guy
shorter than me before
because maybe that's because 15 yeah
actually I'm in the top one percent of
height for like female I can't be that I
mean
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go down to
like five fives
no issue okay before all right guys
don't get me wrong it's not the
preference let's get these super chats
red okay I'm at this point in time guys
um thank you for the super chats you
guys have helped us with so many Studio
updates we how many cameras we got
blessed we got like one two we got nine
cameras um we now um thanks to all of
your donations we can shoot in 8k um
which was really big recording 8K and
Stream in 4k which is really big up I
don't think anyone else is doing that in
the Space streaming Okay so it's Matt we
also got all this new lighting thanks to
you guys's donations
um so we really appreciate it guys I am
still in shock by how much the show has
grown in the past um seven months you
guys got us to almost 700 000 if you
guys subscribe hopefully almost 700 000
subscribers in seven months which is
absolutely Max
um our goal is to hit a million by New
Year's so please please please hit that
subscribe button um we have new content
every day including shorts clips and
live streams
um so I think right now blessing what's
it called the the camera holder thing
that you want
he wants a monopod so if you guys send
donations it's going directly for
blessings monopod that's going to help
us when we're doing Street interviews it
like it keeps it balanced right yeah
yeah so that that's the new thing is we
want now that we've upped the show
production we want to up the
um Street interview production too so
thank you for the donation so
um also guys all donations today are
going to be read so even if it's under a
low amount so 90 free top head
war is coming soon we'll see the death
of feminism
um wojeski Borkowski don't try to
understand women women understand and
spite each other the UK economists could
your guests explain their what their
daily duties would be if they're with a
provider man do they know there's work
involved numbers guy
um none of you or your innards are
special or much different stop and think
there's a difference between watching
corn and Performing all corn
War warps all corn warps most young
man's mind mind of sex it's a bad
example he was saying uh I can't say
your last name I'm sorry feminism got it
wrong when they said that women ought to
act like pit act like pigs Ben Shapiro I
didn't do it shorty on the left in the
gray is a baddie I didn't know UK had it
like that out there by far the best one
I've seen on The Show by far numbers
guys zero um it's not lying as much as
they're unable to live in a world of
probabilities instead they yearn at all
possibilities have cake and eat it Zoro
lost a boss babe equals a masculine
woman a promiscuous equal woman equals a
304. men equals a 304 maker your past
and Body Count Matters To Men We want
femininity submissive fit no 304s
numbers guy Senegal isn't wrong there's
a difference between relationship
attention and recreational use only he's
referring to recreational use only Kalia
Andrews A woman can't be a simp if there
were a simping they would be technically
submissive and much happier for it
Nicholas nasty you will lose a lot of
money chasing women but you won't lose
any women chasing money Porgy monogamy
is not loyalty from a man we were loyal
with our provisions and ladies don't
virtue signal when you know most women
are as loyal as their options thank you
another kid for the Super Chat how is
Cheryl
thank you for the 100 super challenge
[Applause]
sponsor right now
um sent two so two cool Auntie sorry to
hear about the tracksuit as a
consolation I figured out
um how I figured out you teach youngans
to grow up why because the good Lord a
healing man taught the law similarly
similarly King riches teaches young men
to grow up because again the good Lord
was a painter derivative I I know the
law of Samurai only allow babies or
grieving mothers to cry pretty girls are
never allowed to cry this is the law
puppies are sore Paws and expected but
only on Fridays everyone must obey their
laws toodle pie been here since 285 how
was that though I don't know I just read
them
um Porgy Jr men stop chasing they never
want the guy who does that no more
simping
um Zora slat 1-1 a single woman in her
late 20s and on has been lied to by
feminism and has turned into the
masculine independent independent man
you've always wanted to marry Let me
refresh it also guys like the video we
have over 2 000 people in here live
watching so I think I think that we
should have at least a thousand likes on
the video at least I think 2 000
honestly because some of you guys dip in
and dip out so really like the video and
subscribe to the channel let's draw one
two three would like to see if there's
data between there's I would like to see
if there's data that's been collected
from only fans porn or cornhub on what
age groups of men are the ones paying
for subscriptions based on pornography
silly sausage I think the ladies
should all have to work two years as a
bricklayer or shovel shoveling gravel
like like conscription I reckon I would
it would help them understand what some
men they date actually have to do okay
that's all of them okay all righty
um
listen we are ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna watch a video at this moment in
time and I just want you to get I just
want to get your thoughts on it and
we've seen as we're talking about
simping
um if blessing could kind of cue the
video
um because we're talking about simping
and in my personal point of view
this is simping 101. okay let's see
um let's see uh that's good everybody is
your boy oh shade Duke Jackson
back at it again with another episode of
the saw Liberty dunk Brothers
I want to take it back I don't care how
old you are but if you're 50 60 under
you you know what I'm talking about
right
when you're in high school if you're the
average guy you're not getting that much
play are we gonna be real about it
you're not getting that much play
women do not want nothing to do with
your ass alright then what happens is
you get a little older get a little bit
of money and a lot of times you know in
your 20s a lot of chicks that you want
to do in your 20s they ain't got time
for you right but you know what Bobby
Blue Bland the famous singer
had a quote one day he calls it and says
it further on up the Rope further on up
the road what does that actually mean
okay that means that as time progresses
in life things change that's what my
mama you saw my girlfriend said I always
say age brings about a change all right
now for those of you who don't want to
believe that as my Grandma I said keep
living okay keep on living keep living
now as you keep living you're gonna find
out some black men
a lot of the women who didn't want
anything to really do with you
all of a sudden
you see them in Walmart
you know like I was in Walmart like when
I was back home and I I'm running into
people oh you know we see you on YouTube
you know we see you doing things you
know he was always a guy I wanted to
talk to all kind of stuff now now I'm
the guy that y'all want to talk to now
right and but now we've never seen it in
real time like we're seeing it with
Angela Simmons and Yo Gotti
this is astonishing right now when
Angela Simmons was in her what would
consider her beauty Prime
and I'm not saying anything's wrong with
her right now because it's not but if we
want to be fair her beauty Prime for
whatever reason Yo Gotti she was not
interested Yo Gotti was doing everything
he could to talk to her in fact Angela
Simmons turned down
uh I believe Master P son Laura was
Romeo Miller and then we know what
happened with Sutton Tennyson God Rest
his soul he passed away because he was
he was killed then even after that she
didn't want nothing to do with him
she wanted to do with him all right he
was still in the inbox he been wanting
her for a long time ain't want didn't
want nothing to do with him at all she
even got what this boxer do
uh Daniel Jacobs
even the boxer dude didn't want her no
more all right so the boxer due to her
broke up Angela Simmons even
contemplated can I date white men
I'm open to dating white men
almost ready to date my ugly ass okay
almost
but now what did we find out
like Grandma said age brings about a
change okay that's what age does it
brings about a change now all of a
sudden we saw Angela Simmons
hanging out with Yo Gotti in Atlanta she
was doing her little stupid dances and
stuff like that and to the song he was
sitting up there looking like an idiot
we saw that
been afterwards what did we see now
we're seeing them hanging out in Dubai
okay now here's what I want to talk
about and here's a danger in some of
this for some of you guys out there
all right this is very important Yo
Gotti represents many of you guys
who for whatever reason
um
and the prime you wanted to get this
chick
she would not deal with you I don't care
if it's Instagram models
some of you guys are working real hard
to get IG models she don't want to deal
with you at all but now here you are you
have the money you've built yourself up
you look different now you're going back
to chase the people that didn't want to
do nothing to do with you I see it all
the time and guess what's going to
happen they're only dealing with you
because of convenience
that's what you got to understand you
can't look at it as man I finally got
the girl that I wanted think about it as
why did I get her
she really don't want to be with me
because if she really wanted to be with
me when I first tried to be with her she
would have had time now we can say all
kind of stuff what can we say guys we
can say stuff like this
we can say well you know what sometimes
I'm gonna have boyfriends they're doing
X Y and Z they're doing that they're
doing okay for many many different
things we can come up with all the
excuses in the book as to why she don't
want your ass it's fine with me it's
fine with me we can we can try to
explain it if you if it make you feel
better let's explain it the fact is she
didn't want you then now she wants you
why does she want you I would want to
know that why you want me now
even if you have a chick that you
dealing with her and all of a sudden
start acting funny and then all of a
sudden she want to deal with you again
why you want me all of a sudden right
now
I was missing you
me fall for that [ __ ] don't you fall for
that because that's exactly what a lot
of ladies want you to do to be which is
dumb want you to believe
that you feel like you so special the
reason why they dealing with you is
because they miss you no it usually is
you're a backup plan you know somebody
needs to make her feel good for the time
being and that's what and that's what
your job is you're there to do that okay
some of y'all I need to understand
natural role all right you're gonna be
self-assuring making her feel good about
herself
all right that's it as long as you know
that's what it's about it's gonna be
okay but now once you start feeling like
it's gonna be real it's gonna be real as
as until whatever you can do for her
because the reality is she might have
hit a wall now I'm gonna play actually
I'm gonna go there I'm gonna do it
straight women are hitting the wall and
finding what out guys think about it
that they're not what they used to be
look at Amber Rose crying all over
social media she can't get a rich man
this is no different than Angela Simmons
Angela Simmons has found out it's harder
now she don't look bad and Summers don't
look bad it's harder though it's harder
when you have more competition in the in
the amount of guys you can deal with
already are taken that's what makes it
difficult it is difficult it is not easy
so that's why she's dealing with your
guiding no more all of a sudden he's
short oh his height don't bother me so
much no more what's what's not bothering
them so much no more is that the
opportunities are not there it's not
there where are the guys that's going to
be there for these ladies where are the
guys that are going to spend all that
money on these ladies you're not going
to see it they know that that's why
they're going back to the guys that they
neglected before and the question is is
it going to be you now I understand it's
okay for a woman to want a man that's
going to have some money and have
something I'm all for that but insofar
as you didn't give me no attention and
all of a sudden I'm gonna be dealing
with you now hell no keep that energy
let somebody else take care of you bye I
go deal with somebody who we want to be
with me why I gotta deal with you I'm
not gonna be dealing with you
for what but if you didn't want to deal
with me what I wanted you to do get your
ass
get your ass out of there okay
um right ladies and gents we're talking
about simping
to to summarize Yo Gotti it's 41 year
old man okay he is a successful
millionaire rapper and this woman in
2016 Angela Simmons he expressed
interest in her she was actually in a
relationship
she had a she had a child for another
man
and
that man died
after he died she went with little Romeo
showing Danny Jacobs and then
she gave Yo Gotti the time in 2022. burn
that yo got his idiot Yo Gotti so but Yo
Gotti waited six years he's an idiot
okay we're gonna get to that he waited
six years we're talking about simping
six years to get the woman of his
quote-unquote dreams I don't think it uh
it falls down to that I think after that
he just as a man
ego Maybe
he thought
you know he still has that chance and
he's tried and tried and he's gotten
there now she get and I think it's more
about that no I think as a woman when a
man tries too hard you lose respect for
him right you do but that woman does not
respect him she's with him for other
reasons she's not with him because she
wants him whatever reason she's with him
that's up to her in it but him as a man
he should know and he should see that
that woman does not respect him she's
already had her little fun she's went on
and had her fun went out with the guys
that she wanted and now she wants to
settle with him
well you see I've got to the point where
no one's no one wants him wants her now
right this this was my point uh yeah go
on bro this is my point earlier woman
there's always a sound would go for the
gold
until
they ain't got nothing and then they go
back to the call right right so yeah the
security guys
right yeah so your God is a doorman
right now yeah so remind me
um how old are you I know you're 21
you're image are you guys yeah well 21.
so are you I'm 24 24. okay so you're the
oldest one here do you find that to be
common that girls will curve guys in
their early 20s and they give them a
chance later
not me personally me personally
I feel like if I've gone for a guy that
was initially interested in me
time before another guy is because
another guy has I'm distracted by
something flashy it doesn't necessarily
mean I've settled for you but it's now I
know issue because whatever was flashing
in my face ain't there no more but
wouldn't you say that the thing that was
flashy was your first choice because
it's kind of like
if something more flashy comes along you
should lose interest in the flashing
because say I see something flashing in
the distance and I think oh I want that
I get closer it's but
bottle cap that was flashing against the
light it could be alert it just looked
nice from first glance from instance now
when I get close off find out more get
more substance I found out okay what
initially attracted me okay that's not
why I mean let me let me ask the guys
though guys are you waiting six years
for the six years for the woman that you
won he didn't wait hang on six years for
the woman that you want and during those
six years you can see she's got with X Y
and Z man and then you're like yeah
like are you doing that yeah no I'm not
doing that bro I'm not doing that I'm
doing that she's in the public either
there's no way I could do that for me
personally even in the past when I think
of people who have tried to do that
where they want to come back and be like
oh yeah you know I actually like you
it's like wait so you like me when you
went out with him
you know what it's different if it's
golf on road because the guy she was
waiting it's worse now when it's on a
public platform and she probably got
with famous rappers etc etc
it's because they're already public so
people are just going to know nobody
because gossip gossip is possible
for six years and the thing is remember
it's a long time
that's not the point he's still trying
in his song in 2006 he mentioned her in
one of his songs in 2016. right saying
that he wanted he wanted her it's 2016.
she was with her man cool that's fine
she was with a man her man died in 2008
died in 2018.
she in 2018 went to Lil Romeo but but
maybe she didn't go to him right yeah
and so off little Romeo then she was
Danny Jacobs and he's still expressing
interest he was the next in line and
then
off the teddy Jacobs she's like well
I'll give you a chance now and he's like
yes
that is their choice
I can't like even as a woman I would
know a man especially a man if you're
doing that you're a [ __ ] I'm so
sorry
me as a woman I'm not doing that if you
have me once I'm never showing you again
right personal a new FM man does that if
he keeps shouting me and shouting me I'm
just gonna look at you like a beg I'm
not gonna that's exactly these girls
never been in a position year where a
guy will try so hard yeah quite a long
time yeah and then you give him that
time no after a while yeah no yeah
I can't lie it's not like give you the
the thingy trans there and then oh I'm
never giving you the chance
it depends how they do it
that was more comment like I feel like
if I ever gave them a chance like like
what I realized later is if I really
liked you I would have given you a
chance
and I think like sometimes them you know
you could end up dating them or whatever
but they're still not who you want to be
with nope nope we're all kind of single
here yeah that's true but yeah it could
work out I don't know sorry go bro yeah
I was thinking if it's definitely a case
for you single people but
um uh let me not say it like that
you know I'm brought back to I've been
to like three four weddings this year
one of them was my dad he got married in
Cyprus oh
um
one of them was my Uncle Eric now my
Uncle Eric sadly he's had some health
issues but
his partner despite his sickness always
loved him so they were high school
that's the whole point of her being in a
relationship she ended up breaking up in
their 20s and then they went there
for almost 30 years not dating each
other not seeing each other not speaking
to each other she had a picture of him
on her dashboard she used to just say oh
that's my men but not tell people who it
was you know and now they're married
happily married beautiful couple and
people wish they were together for years
you know so see that's different though
because they were together at some point
and they separated they had different
views in life they wanted to do
different things they didn't click but
they came back years after that's
different why did they break up
um she she wanted something different at
the time yeah see what I'm saying that
she probably wanted something different
he wanted something different but then
they came back but as a woman if you if
she curved him and he tried for 30 years
after 30 years and then she gave him
that chance then you know it's not
actually because she likes you I don't
know that sounds sketch to me I'm like
the streets were I'm like the streets
were calling if she broke up with him
girls don't leave and hope to do worse
let's not say anything they're married
Angela Simmons is now a widowed single
mom and she's 35. yeah right so hang on
but Yo Gotti is a 41 year old man who's
kind of doing well for himself how many
babies I don't know how many but what
I'm saying is as a 41 year old man yeah
why is a 35 year old's widowed baby mama
shout out to the baby mama
I think you could be a baby mom look at
it and you can no it's not long
well I get that I don't have a kid in it
so I can't read it but what I'm saying
there's nothing wrong because you could
have a kid so you're telling me a a
woman that has a child has uh she don't
have a chance to no a woman that has a
child I'm not saying that she doesn't
um
she comes with something else men value
Purity yeah and they value youth this is
right
now that's what meant value right so
you've come to me with a man or
something with a child yeah that is not
mine right yeah when men want to get
with a woman they want to create their
child right that's exactly but then
you're looking at the wrong guy wait
wait wait wait wait wait you don't
understand the Mind of Men that's what
I'm trying to I'm trying to no I
understand because there is men
wait
men want to create their legacy with a
woman okay what you're bringing to me is
another man's Legacy but guys have bad
baby mums yeah and it's okay
that goes back to it's the guys you deal
with because again again even
historically a good portion of men
didn't even reproduce 40 of men didn't
even reproduce historically it's a very
small percentage of men that have
multiple baby mums that's not common
with the men that you know that are
around no he's coming nowadays
back in the days
it's not common nowadays it's common
with the men that you guys deal with
because those are in the top 20 percent
of men I'm not dealing with no one's
baby that I don't know
sorry so uh basically earlier you were
saying he was asking them about
them being with with a virgin right like
most women don't want to be with a
virgin right yeah so are gone for us
would you would you rather be with
someone who slept with five guys or
would you be as a man yeah as a man as a
man we prefer to say easy that is such a
disease
we prefer to teach a woman
than a woman to be out there in the
streets and she's come to you exactly
that's what we prefer so women prefer a
man to know what he's doing which means
he's already been in the streets right
and then he can teach you
I have a question for the men how many
okay for girls of 10 how many points
does it subtract a kid so if she's a 10
with no kids how many points does a kid
subtract wow she becomes a five five is
out hey Sarah what about you
for each kid how much does it subtract
from experience I've been with a woman
who's had a child uh-huh and you could
be a 10 you go down to at least a six
okay what about you so Four Points what
about you
um for me it would depend on whether
she'd allow me to parent as well and it
depend on like yeah okay okay bro if you
don't want someone you know my Dad yeah
I'm just asking what how many 10 minus
how much it it it would depend on the
relationship I'd only say one point one
point
wait wait you only say one point because
you haven't experienced it yeah no I
will also say though the reason why both
of you are saying what you're saying
yeah because you are with women who
didn't make space I'm not with a woman
separately with women who didn't make
the space for you to be a parent in that
situation as well and because you
weren't in that situation it was
terrible because you had no respect
which is what we've been speaking about
you want to be in a relationship bro but
can I say something
I'm not gonna lie
a woman
calm down a woman who has a child will
let you know it's their job yeah that's
my point yeah
I'm saying a woman who has a child who
is theirs will whoever consciously or
subconsciously let you know that's not
your child I feel like if you date a
single woman I feel like if you date a
single mother as a guy you should be
able to cheat that's how I feel yeah oh
wow no no hear me out here
I'll tell you why because his mating
strategy strategy is if we go back to
our biology right it's to screw as many
people as possible and ensure paternity
our our mating strategy is to get
resources from a guy so you get your
mating strategy and and commitment from
the guy so you get your mating strategy
fulfilled and he has to deal with
someone else's kid nah like you cheated
on him by not waiting for marriage to
have a child
wait wait wait
so so I I think you you basically
cheated on him by not giving him Purity
and youth I mean you can't give him
Purity you can't give him wait wait wait
you can't give him Purity if you have a
child you can't that's true and so it's
like if you don't offer that why would
you expect monogamy
but it's a different time now you know
like you're two kids your two kids were
back in the days no it's not different
times
ladies ladies let me try and give you
some game yeah seriously you don't
understand the minds of men no they
don't they don't really don't understand
you're sitting with one two three I do
blessing over there four men we're
trying to give you the minds of men you
are not listening to us
no but wait but wait but wait I'm saying
meant value purity
and we value youth can I not say I wait
for [ __ ] sake like let me [ __ ]
speak men value speak Purity and youth
okay you can among amongst your girls
have whatever conversation that you want
to have amongst your girls women live in
an echo chamber amongst their women all
the time oh yeah girl he's this yeah you
can do that all the time when you come
out of that Echo chamber and you speak
to men there's reality there you get the
reality and that's and wait you'll put
your hand down what I'm trying to say to
you is right when the one of the main
problems in this Society is women do not
listen to when men speak and when men do
speak right they call them misogynistic
they call them all kinds of names that
they want to call them right but what
you're not listening to is
men are speaking and they're telling
their truth
this is man's truth if you come to me
with a child two children three children
you are not our first choice
I'm telling you you don't have children
so it's cool you no man wakes up as your
if you talk about Yo Gotti he's 41 years
old he did not wake up in the morning
thinking you know the woman that I
actually want to have for my long-term
partner is a widowed okay baby what is a
widowed baby mama that's my first choice
to be realistic but I'm saying nobody oh
my god seriously
generally men that is not their first
choice no it's not their first choice do
you think men wake up thinking they want
baby mamas as as their as their
long-term part what you're saying and
they don't want that so what I'm trying
to say to you is when you're a baby
mother you lose points so we are
settling for baby mamas if if a man has
a baby mama he's settling
I think a baby Mama does not need to be
that job no no you I've had to step it
doesn't matter what you think
listen to what I'm saying my mom would
change wait it doesn't matter what you
think no I'm I'm not saying no wait it
doesn't matter what you think I think
we're talking about what men think we're
not talking about what you think and
this man wait who wants my mind my
goodness gracious my dear woman do you
do you want to hang on wait wait wait we
as men understand the minds of women we
understand what women want generally as
yes we do
trust me
because you won't come say I want this
and I want that she actually doesn't
want that right so we understand that
women want General things we like to
play you want security do you want
security of course everyone okay do you
want to protect her of course do you
want a provider of course
protectors and providers and people who
do that we understand as men that's what
we've got to be the problem is as women
you don't understand what men want you
think you understand what men want and
the reason why you think you understand
what men want is because you live within
an echo chamber of your girlfriends true
you have not come out of that Echo
chamber and asked men what do you want
from us as women yeah so hang on when
women do
you say oh that's misogynistic no that's
just what men want so as men we can
actually understand this we can actually
Talk Amongst ourselves and say this is
what we are as men want but you think
because of your Echo chamber
that's misogynistic okay how many how
many
um dads are out there let's say I'm a
dad oh yeah Dad yeah I'm a dad too these
are that's lovely there you go shout out
to the kids so I've seen women that are
baby mums get with a guy that respects
his child her child
respects her and the whole situation way
more than the actual real baby that did
sorry say that again repeat that what
I'm trying to say is that I've seen
women that have kids
they in guys she's obviously like
separated divorce whatever
she's dating other guys and Dave
actually and they've respected this yes
way more than maybe their own dad has
yeah but respect and love okay do you
know what because he's a good guy do you
know what I'll blame the girl because
she was with the wrong guy in the first
place okay I hear it but what I'm trying
to say is that like it don't it does to
say that not every guy thinks that you
know because she's got a child
it's because he doesn't have any other
options it's because his pickings
weren't that good honestly there's four
like one there's 41 forms of birth
control like why are you getting
pregnant with like maybe with this
random like I don't understand why these
girls are getting babies left and right
41 forms of birth control but you can be
married get and have a kid that doesn't
mean okay but then but then you have a
duty don't leave which means women women
leave it women leave
um 70 of the time if they're college
educated they leave 90 of the time
correct women ruin relationships and
they ruin families women women typically
do it actually so if a guy ask the
majority of men their first choice is
not a baby mother just like just like
our first choice typically is not a
short broke guy that's right it's the
same thing it's the same thing now now
will we put up with a guy that's shorter
if he's good looking sure well will a
guy put up with a single mother if she
has some other things that she brings to
the table maybe she's attractive maybe
she has other stuff maybe she's
submissive whatever it is that he values
yeah but it's most men it is not their
first choice okay but maybe that woman
that has a child has more to offer than
a woman that doesn't and you're talking
as a woman you don't see him
what you just said is an example of
simping and that's exactly what we've
been talking about discussed today if a
guy would go out of his way to give more
to a woman who already has a child he's
doing that because he knows that if he
wants to be with a woman he's actually
got to show respect to the child so he
has to simp actually he's got to do more
he's got to give more to be in that
relationship right and this this is what
this is why we're here talking about it
it's not it's not just effort because
she's she's not gonna have to do that
for him
like when you're when you're a single
mother and you get married you get all
the benefits and he had so so it's like
we we get bailed out of a bad decision
like you made a poor choice and instead
of taking your bed and lying in it you
get bailed out by some sense why do you
have to lie in a bed that maybe is very
harmful for yourself though because you
made him poor twice I've been in a
relationship as well yeah single like
where the the girl has a baby they don't
let you attack some some girls they
don't let you meet their babies that's
right something is and you can't
discipline no anyone yeah
let me speak first of all you don't you
you don't get to see the child you don't
get to sit down with them and until
things are serious and clear to her that
you that you're showing intention you're
so intention right so uh so for me as a
man if you let me underst understood
from the beginning okay I have a child
but first of all I'm not gonna let you
meet my child for the first six months
that we're dating
their dad or his dad or her dad comes
around every now and then to check to to
check on them so you have to respect
that right if she makes everything clear
to you from the beginning right and you
have feelings for her despite her having
a child I don't condemn that right you
can be with a with a single mother and
build a family yeah with alongside that
that child has been there already right
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
yeah there's there's nothing wrong with
it's an adult situation no but but then
for a man no but then I'll get to a
point right yeah sorry if if like
there's no problem they're eating or
marrying a single woman a single mother
right yeah but uh but but there is this
situation where
this is you you you made me lose
but then but then what's sorry saying as
a man we don't put as a single mother as
our first choice of course it's not your
first choice if you have kids yourself
just you you cannot go and tell people
if they can and can't have kids but let
me finish earlier you were saying that
you don't put a virgin guy as your first
choice to have sex with
it
I'll say the same thing and it's not
controversial the men won't get upset a
single father isn't my first choice
right most women most women don't care
because because the thing is like when a
man has multiple children it signals to
to most women that other women have
selected him and like actually I've
heard from single dads that they get
more women after they have kids so I'm
not the norm but I I can I've said on
this plot podcast multiple times single
father not my first choice and it's not
controversial but like women get
triggered I don't know why no but the
figures
I'm a father and I understand this is
what yeah
so many times I don't care I have a
child and I understand I'm not woman's
First Choice I'm and I'm cool with me I
understand can I say something no no no
wait let me finish though
I'm a single father and I understand
that I'm not woman it's real because
I've got a child and I may have quote
unquote baggage that I'm bringing With
Me true when you say that to a woman ah
yo but hang on but why don't you
understand the same thing that's that's
the selfishness
don't go to say that um a woman that has
a child is less valuable in your eyes a
woman that has a child is less valuable
to a man wait wait wait wait not to not
to herself and not to her girlfriends
yeah and that's what I said women need
to step out of their Echo Chambers and
start asking men hang on you need to
start asking men what they value and the
problem is when you start asking men
shout out rest in peace Kevin Samuels
okay
he he highlighted this and he
highlighted that when men speak and when
men think and when men feel and when men
Express their opinions right
women that are single mothers of like
two three four or however many children
fat chicks too right you have to
understand how men speak and how men
feel and it offends you
that's not our problem can I ask you but
men are allowed to have their standards
wait wait Amanda with a man when a woman
has standards men are not offended if
you say you don't want shoot guys all
right cool you don't want to shoot guys
but the man says I don't want a baby
mother oh my God
it's like you get offended it's like
it's crazy you're not allowed to have
standards too I'm not gonna lie I don't
want a baby that evil he a man could
actually have all the things that he did
everything and if he has kids I'm like
no did that straight away from the man
that actually says raw listen I don't
want this this is not what I want but
you as a woman have to understand that
that's not his standard no but I tell
you something so would you you will
break all of your rules for the right
guy
if you ask kids [ __ ] no no no
I guarantee you when you will break all
of your rules I have been in a situation
I'm your virgin let me just ask you a
question are you a virgin no yeah right
so I'm a financial version
that guy has a baby all right so I'm not
gonna
I'm not going into a relationship but
then at the same time you're not even a
virgin no no no no no can I say why can
I say why I would not give a guy the
chance can I say why I would not give a
guy that has kids because me as a person
I know myself and I can't give those
kids the love that they require that's
the reason why I can't I can't be around
someone else's child that I know he's
had another woman and I already know as
a man you know you're gonna go and do
your little ting tingling with your baby
mom let's be real now no I believe
I I agree with you like a single thought
like again it wouldn't be my first
choice it wouldn't because I just think
there's baggage that comes with that
exactly but you get it but like why when
Sarah was saying the same thing you guys
were like but that doesn't make her less
valuable no because the way he said that
just sounds
great
you know you just got to you got to
feeling
we don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
we're talking about the facts the fact
is I understand as a man that being a
father of another child I understand
that a lot of women may say I'm a curb
that guy I'm not taking that guy because
he's got a child I understand that and
I'm cool with that and that's a fact my
feelings don't come into that situation
the problem is is that when you say the
same thing to women oh but I feel like
we don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
because you know why it's the same thing
you can go for a second then you can go
down you know I think the difference is
why all the girls were saying and it
goes back to what he said your guy you
two are saying if a guy has a child
she's a five but it completely depends
on the child the relationship with the
child like I might meet a guy his baby
mom's tapped always involved that's a
that's a thought immediate side chick
though no no no
okay so so you're so you're saying it
depends based on the girl that's what
you're saying and it depends on how the
person let's if you have someone that
doesn't let you paint their child at all
how can that ever work okay so you're
looking at it from a woman's point of
view yeah because for us it depends
based on this because my mom let a guy
parent me your mom yeah
I don't know I don't know your personal
situation I'm not going to speak on like
your life I don't know it but I'm saying
I'm saying in general it's not men's
first choice
and it really doesn't matter the
situation I I don't know who your
stepdad is but typically it's lower
status men that don't have a ton of
options because if you look at the men
with the money and the power and that
have the most options they tend to pick
young single childless women
again
no I totally agree with you I've been
brought with boys like men my uncle my
dad so I fully understand that I feel
like it doesn't matter what color
caliber man is that whether he's got
money or poor or whatever they still do
go for the same thing with it's pure
innocent they still go for the same
thing because at the end of the day as I
said before earlier what I was trying to
touch on is that in our nature men want
to be a provider they want to so
therefore they want to their legacy to
go on and therefore right to the
[Music]
yes so so not not all of them you know
one girl might get minus five or let's
say seven points because her baby daddy
was you know in jail yeah but and one
might and one might guess
oh no but but the point is but you're
missing the point the point is
regardless if you have a child you get
points unattracted I know that's why
that's what I was saying I know I know
he's got a child okay you got a child
yeah yes Ralph how old is your child
he's three he's three how old are you
I'm 21. okay so hang on this is this is
great so did I make it too fast no no
but you're a 21 year old yeah with a
three-year-old yeah which means you have
your child at 18. yes okay ask her how
hang on no no it's not even that I'm
saying do you think so the type of man
that you're looking for the type of man
that you may be looking for yeah right
you have to understand that that man he
because you're 21. yeah you may be
looking for a 27 year old maybe at this
point in time right I will be looking at
somebody else yeah like you might be
looking for a guy who's like 27.'s
mature yeah a bit more older than you
yeah if a guy's 27
yeah that means he's in his
quote-unquote prime of life okay he's
building that he's building himself up
to be a man yeah do you think a man
who's building himself up to be a man
he's looking to take on another man's
shirt
to be honest is that what you think like
I said then it all comes down to
different like everyone's different and
everyone's Minds different everyone's
mindset generally do you think generally
you think a single 27 year old generally
no he probably is looking for a single
one without any children that's her
exactly but no but no at the same time
right if if I meet a girl yeah and she's
21 23 whatever yeah and she's a single
mom but she was married
and she had a baby in a marriage
I would look at her that's different
it's different now
different right let me make a point bro
let me make a point
if she was married and she has a baby in
the in that marriage and then
at some time the marriage collapse right
I would I would I wouldn't I wouldn't
look at her the same as as this as this
road lady that's just right now
different right this is the this is the
mindset of Madness and the minds of men
this is our minds what an 18 year old
unmarried woman I was married you were
married
I sound corrected so you're a married
woman of 18 that had a child I didn't
even know that brother right okay
so what I'm trying to say do you
understand how men's Minds differ
because because if you were an unmarried
woman but maybe because if you want
unmarried woman at 18 that had a child
that wasn't committed to a relationship
yeah you were just some random chick
men would be like nah nah
can I ask you guys a question
is there a difference between a woman
that's married or in a long-term
relationship we just say this no no no
no no no no no no no no but listen for
hours no no listen because
see my brother
to my brothers they're Muslim so they do
the marriage thing quick right so
they'll meet someone maybe they'll get
married after a couple of weeks to my
brothers a couple of weeks yeah like
it's a quick that's how it is
a couple of weeks
I get married by the first look this is
what I'm saying I've heard of that
that's why the empty by they get married
in that culture they have things like
Arrangement it's like it's a quicker
process than in like Western Society
like in Western Society it will take you
a lot longer to get married so in
essence I'm I'm asking what's the
difference between some let's say she
got married says
uh free well I got married pretty quick
as well so this is what I mean were you
Muslim or something I'm Muslim yeah this
is what I mean how long were you married
for uh so I got married after three
months
so let's say I've been in a relationship
with a guy for five years we've not been
married yeah okay for whatever reason
now let's say she's been she got married
after three months do you see a
difference
wait wait okay so I'll tell you how men
see it it's like what to them to that to
them to them it's like why weren't you
worth marrying so so to me to to them
it's like oh she got married after three
months I I trust men like trust each
other to vet women so to them it's like
then there's something wrong with you
because you were with like one they
would ask why would you be with a guy
for five years without marriage and then
two like why didn't he think you were
worth marrying me personally and I'm not
trying I'm not trying to be like no no
rude but I'm saying like that's just how
men view it me personally I don't put
much value on marriage because can I
just give it and wait wait and so I I
understand like where where you're
coming from because like honestly the
marriage contract is so bad nowadays
like it's it's it's horrible and I I
mean I understand like why men don't
want to get married and I especially in
the west and in the UK yes I'm 100 with
you but like to her so like let's say
you both had a child the men would look
at her and say she was so Val she was so
valuable to that guy that he was that
she was worth it like like to like he
was willing to take that risk for her
and so she gets like a higher status and
I'm not and I'm not saying that's that's
right or fair I'm just saying like this
this is how this is this is how men view
it
was a virgin and he wouldn't have sex
guys will just give you a kid now just
not raise it because no they don't have
to bury it they don't don't have at the
end of the day see when I have a kid
it's in me I have to push out and I'm
left with it
women but women wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait
please respect that [ __ ] holes you're
gonna get muted stop okay so this is the
thing like
women pick those men and and I just
don't buy that women are Bamboozled and
they have no idea that these no I don't
believe that right and so I don't
believe that so we we are we are in
control of sex we have 41s 41 forms of
birth control yeah abortions are are
free here and legal so we are completely
in control of who is born that woman
deserves what she gets yeah yeah yeah
because I'm 30 and I have no kids four
reasons right right that's what I'm
saying I believe the goal that gets
pregnant by a guy yeah exactly
is an abortion so no but what I'm trying
to say is if you don't believe in
abortion don't let man you and then
let's have sex without Consciousness but
you could have contraception and still
get pregnant I think what Paul's saying
is we should be responsible yeah but
it's a person it's very it's very and
I'm not I know you have a kid so I'm not
trying to come at you but of course you
get an IUD that's 99.5 effective you
only really get pregnant three to five
days in the month when you're ovulate I
know there's exceptions but every girl
every girl that I know personally that
had an abortion or had an unwanted
pregnancy personally I just go off of
what I see in real life and the numbers
they were irresponsible in some way like
some of the girls weren't on birth
control and you were letting him finish
in you what was wrong if you know you're
not on birth control
and you get pregnant and you don't
believe in abortions personally
that's your business let me ask you a
question though as a as the woman who
has who was seeing another men's yeah
right oh I've seen another man yeah
who's got a woman yeah if you got
pregnant would you keep his baby no no
no you wouldn't I as much as
um I would say that you love him and you
always when I say love is this I used to
love the word love very Loosely however
no I would never put myself in that
position
I just know he's willing to cheat and I
like him and his and you're happy
is he simple for you because that's what
it kind of says
no but you said when he calls you when
you call him you don't pick up but when
he calls you you pick up right he called
you no do you know why yeah
let me explain because basically he has
a goal right so I don't have a man so I
have no attachments no I have to hide
the secret from you it's him true all
right so I'll say and potentially
don't no no thank you I'm not delusional
that's the one listen Okay okay if I
call him potentially he might be with
his God all right so do you have a
potential let me ask you a question so
do you have other men then yes
so you do yeah how how long like because
you're 30. I'm like no I'm saying I'm
just genuinely wait wait wait so
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35. so
five years yeah and and in that time you
have to get to know someone convince
them to do you know because wait wait
wait how how long do you want to play
these games no no realistically I have
guys that I could just give me a baby
would look after the baby they're good
friends than me yeah but you wouldn't
give him yeah
right right right right we literally if
if I really thought listen I my time's
up I need to have a kid there's guys I
could do that with if that's what I want
right but I'm just no I'm just no I'm
just genuinely
no no it's not it's not it's not a thing
so so
so so I'm just genuinely asking like how
long do you want to play these games see
me I don't know
sorry sorry
it was the edge sorry sorry but I just
I'm saying don't give me a long sentence
just how long do you want to play these
games for don't just answer until I meet
someone I want to have a kid with okay
can I ask you a question now can I ask
you a question at this moment at this
very moment would you get rid of a baby
I mean a committed relationship that I
care for that they've shown that they
have good traits to be a father to be a
good husband or if I got to an age that
was just too old that I thought I'm 40
and I'm single I have very good good
male friends
so it's just like if I was in your shoes
like [ __ ] if if I'm gonna be a side
chick anyway I would just compete figure
out what the hell he wants to try to be
it like if I was if if that's what
you're gonna do anyway or like or just
get it off
I'm I'm gonna go a little bit deeper
right yeah
and go to self-esteem yeah
if you are a woman who is happy yeah
self-esteem wise yeah with being with a
man that's not your man right yeah
knowing that he's never going to commit
to you yeah there's a self-esteem issue
there okay so I'm not even gonna answer
this is my cousin so let him answer for
me no because I'm biased right you see
me there's a self-esteem issue there
though see the difference for me is
right if I if I happen to like someone
right the majority because how how much
do you value
how much do you value yourself as a
woman as an individual hang on wait how
much do you value yourself as a woman as
an individual that you will allow
yourself yeah to be constantly chasing
after and just just please just let me
speak right
to allow yourself to be chasing after
another man's I saw another girl's man
right and be happy with that I don't
know what's going on with you inside
your life with this within the 30 years
I don't know right but on a self-esteem
issue right you're actually happy with
this arrangement
you're happy with it I don't chase him
no it doesn't matter
but what I'm trying to say is that
you're happy with that Arrangement
that's so selfish
like someone who who doesn't have no no
selfie are you not gonna let whatsoever
that she's happy to be a side chick yeah
and happy to sleep with with with other
men's around and still in her head think
at some point in her life she will
settle down she'll find her husband she
would build a family yeah because that's
what women generally want impossible
okay I'm just I'm just gonna be real
though most women can and most women do
like yeah yeah it's not with the guys
they want but like it's a Sim epidemic
look at the look at the title The how
many yeah how many step daddies we got
out here that fun but let's just be real
I'm not saying I'm not saying it should
be that way but obviously there's
two you know what I'm saying like I feel
like they want to say side chicks have
low self-esteem whatever and this is
going to be an unpopular opinion but I
just I just feel like there there are a
group of women that will be side chicks
but they compete and they try to steal
your man I'm just saying if you're gonna
do it I I wouldn't sign up I wouldn't
sign up to do it I'm just saying if
you're gonna do it anyway you might look
over the whole race
do you know why I don't want to steal
your mind absolutely someone that's been
excited because I I you cheat so I can't
trust you I don't want to take you from
myself
before me before me before because we're
gonna close out soon but yeah it's good
sex but you know as you because you're
30 right yeah as long as you get to 35
and you get to 40 and you've got no kids
wait wait you got no kids and you've got
no future you looking ahead of you right
that loneliness is gonna set it is
wait let me finish wait let me finish
the loneliness is gonna set in right and
you're gonna look at all of your
girlfriends around you who have got kids
yeah and have got whatever your sisters
maybe your girlfriends blah blah and
you're gonna feel
empty yeah you're gonna feel empty
everything and the thing is it's like
I don't like I don't get it I'm not
gonna I don't I don't understand how
that is your life
can I just say what I think you're
saying and you can tell me yeah that's
fine in your head You're Gonna Keep
sleeping with him because of the good
the good sex that's why and so in your
head you don't want to be with you try
something yeah
so so you're gonna keep sleeping with
him because of the good sex yeah and
until you meet someone new yeah and when
you meet it but you wouldn't if he broke
up with his girlfriend tomorrow you
wouldn't be with him even though you
love even though you love him Loosely
look I don't know I'm just going off on
the words
a year and a half is a long time okay if
I'm just putting myself in your shoes if
I was sleeping with a guy for a year and
a half and he was giving like if I was
in your shoes I would probably be close
to in love with him if not okay I'm just
I'm just so I should apologize for using
in that way so because I use it very
Loosely
okay
okay so I should also explain the reason
why I see this guy as much as I do
because we're in the same Social Circle
now okay okay but I'm on Pearl's side
when it comes to it I'm just saying like
if if you if you look if I was you I I
would either compete for him or get out
because you're not gonna be opened like
we all know we all know when we're
getting like like if you you're not open
to meeting someone I am 100 really I
feel like I'm a very niche market of
person so when I speak my opinion
my constant convulsion is I do not cap
no at the end of the day like I said he
gives good sex and I enjoy sometimes
am I not open to meeting other people
you have sex with other guys right yeah
yeah so I'm saying so
you when you say you're open so you're
literally open
not in that you're literally open yeah
some people post some people I feel like
we're okay with that but for some people
of number of people but obviously he's
like he's there to save mum he's there
in a central to save my body count from
going up okay
let me explain because the other person
that I will now sleep with it's not the
person that oh I just met an oh or the
person that oh I'm horny I need to sleep
with someone it will be the person that
I've been dating okay got to know then
slept with them if it don't work out it
don't work out okay okay I'm just so
remember so you've said the song on a
podcast yeah so I'm just thinking like
long term for you here okay yeah you
have a new guy that's interested I'll
stop sleeping with you okay okay okay
yeah yes yes does he want does he want
to make the mother of his chill like a
potential mother of his kid a girl that
publicly went on a podcast and said I'm
a side chick like I'm just saying I
think I think most men would unders like
I I hate to say this but they're more I
think they'd be more forgiving with a
slightly slightly I didn't say go went
crazy higher body count one or two more
than a girl that was willing to be a
side chick for years okay uh it happened
okay
yeah of course
it's wait wait interrupt me wrong I
swear god
um I haven't slept with him in six
months no speak so so it's it's it's
going to go on years because he's still
in your head like I I can just tell
you're still okay okay sure but sure
okay okay okay okay but he but he's wait
but he's the one that has you yeah I can
tell and you your cousin's nodding yes
okay but like I just know I'm just
saying wait wait as I'm just saying as
as like woman to woman like you know
when a girl's into a guy like that you
know when he's that guy for you like
he's the guy you're breaking the rules
for right he's not been the only one
though that's why okay okay maybe
I've not made enough a side chick
I understand you know that there's a
meme that actually embodies you what's
the name she belongs to the streets
like maybe maybe there's one or two
other guys that it was similar right or
no you have never been okay I know wait
and I I never said like that it was the
same exact situation but maybe you felt
similar for but I I can this is the guy
you've talked about the most on this
podcast he was the first one you brought
up women as women okay okay okay no no
you brought him up before before we you
did not have to bring him up okay
okay I I understand after this okay so
okay okay and so and your cousin's
naught it like you know you know you
know he's that guy to you and you get
enough of him Paul is trying to say he's
not good for your health I know that he
really isn't it
I know that though
okay folks listen
ah this has been the great area
right this has been the great air it's
been a great show but hell before we get
the final thoughts could we just read
out the um I'm gonna apologize now for
what these super chats said yeah I don't
know what they're gonna say yeah I don't
I just know how they tend to go out and
shows like that yeah okay um guys thank
you for the super chats they're all
going um towards blessings I don't even
know what it's mono something camera
holder something blessing oh that's
sweet um again we're trying to up the
camera quality of our street interviews
um we can now record in 8k uh we I also
feel like we should up the mics for our
street interviews
yeah yeah some wireless mics we got some
ideas so
um here are just pearly things we're
always pushing the envelope we always
want to be the best production in the
game uh yeah yeah so I'm selling super
chats if you want to keep seeing the
production quality go up and up and up
okay Nicholas Cornelius hope can be a
double-edged sword it can give one the
courage and strength to pursue what he
wants but also keep him holding on
Beyond what's logical retrospective
thought of a former simp blue Paul
Phoenix a a woman having a kid in a
marriage and them being on the market
later doesn't make it any better because
I bet my last pound she's the one that
initiated divorce um real thumbs say hi
ali um call your Frank Castle Ginger
Spice you need your own version of Frank
Castle came out how does Pearl keep
constantly running into these Muslim
light types 90 free-toe pay would they
want their son to marry a single mom um
lyrically inclined never tried a fool a
Woman by telling her what she wants to
hear tell her the truth and she'll fool
herself Black Ops baby mamas and side
chick material but the simps make them
think they can get better there's
billions of single women on this planet
to choose from Dragon stallion one zero
zero one if the baby daddy was enough
for you you to have opened your legs
then he should have been good enough for
you as a woman to stay with him Sigma
Rose within a week of meeting my fiance
ended within a week of meeting meeting
my fiance ended things with the two
girls he was seeing because I didn't
have kids and they did these women need
to quiet down open their ears and listen
to what the men are trying to tell us 90
free Tope I dated and loved a single mom
you can't apply the same Dating Rules
across the board you know how women can
be they will tell you you're not the dad
Edgar rise Garvey is about to shed flesh
dealing with these ladies he has no hair
to let let him finish
Black Ops if she's a baby mama she's
invisible in my book
you say something probably the worst
episode I've watched all talking over
each other and there's no guys checking
them guy in the Hat had a point but he
couldn't even express it I'm watching
the modern day women's Echo chamber live
wujensi bore something I don't know what
is bigger um Muhammad's biceps or the
gray top girl's lips love for you both
uh Levy one thing I've noticed about all
feminists is once they're independent
and don't need a man I'd like to see how
fast they need an alpha guy in an
extreme event like a power grid going
down World War Society wouldn't be what
it is history history and life is
cynical amen Dana four new mics amen
Dana again guys gotta go back to the
block and get chatting with girls but
those suckers who are out there enjoy
simping you're making these girls think
we're suckers 90 free topic what's funny
is we have only talked about meeting and
dating we haven't even touched marriage
and the exceptions and the expectations
women have out there men do that a lot
let's draw one two three would like to
see if there's a day I think I've said
that one Let me refresh it just to make
sure that there's none left guys like
the video there's over I think there's 2
500 people watching yeah yeah last time
I checked so make sure you guys like the
video we should have at least 2 000
likes
um Pablo marimbo greetings from Chile
thank you for your work
um Catherine Kersey the women sleeping
with a married man probably has the
lowest self-esteem and secretly cries
about her to herself about him in the
quiet of her room the fact that she
lowered herself and stayed status a lot
Nicholas Cornelius oh I'd read that one
okay we can do final thoughts now right
we can do final thoughts I have some
announcements at the end okay no problem
um guys we're gonna go around and girls
let's say however you choose to identify
um we're gonna go around and um you guys
can give your final thoughts on the
subject and then what's just going on
we'll start with Mom
uh I love the ladies first ladies first
no no no you go first sure okay uh well
uh you know uh it's been a very
interesting uh conversation and uh
topics and I hope
woman
in this generation
understand
and are willing to do better you know
because as you say you know
uh I think there's there are so many
good women out there but surrounded by
by the wrong friends
who uh you know who kind of
get into their head and
become a bad influence you know uh
be like your mother
you know because it's real out here you
know others you know you can be a 20 you
can be 21 or 19 look pretty sexy and all
of that but that ain't gonna last
forever and a home a house a home a
family is what we all here for
you know uh and simping is not what's
what's going to get you there
you know if you're a Sim you're never
gonna get a house a home and a family
stop being a simple know what you want
and go for it whether you're a man or a
woman
that's my last words uh there you go hi
this is the India on my final four um on
the same uh personally I think that
um I think that it shouldn't be
generalized as just men uh women can be
sensed as well but at the same time I
think that the word's a bit offensive
slightly I feel like it's just people
trying to go for what they really want
and that's okay that doesn't matter no
matter if you're taking two steps five
steps everything is you know a stepping
stone and yeah really and truly
people should just really try to not
kind of stereotype The Tap Away people
go about certain things
um yeah that's my final thought really
okay on the capture middle
oh me yeah you hi guys
uh my thoughts are well ladies stop
giving your time to just any man don't
open your legs for just anyone and guys
respect yourself
for any girl know what you want what he
said and go for what you want
it's that simple
yeah this is one Dutch hello I feel like
my final thoughts is a good guy in a Sim
this
the lines have been blurred I feel like
it really depends on what a woman's
giving back to you and what you do
because I feel like in society naturally
men give more it just depends how much
more
[Music]
okay
to be honest I just I just think that
man woman in general shouldn't simp
respect yourself a little bit
um but then that doesn't go to say don't
go for what you want it's just when you
see that there's
that no level of Interest or whatever
I'll just find someone else there's so
many people out there you know I don't
know yeah really care um final thoughts
are
if um
yeah if if you feel like you're simping
on someone you feel like you're giving
someone more than they're giving you
uh then you need to just maybe take a
step back and see if actually they
reciprocate what you're given then
um and as a woman I would say that quite
often a lot of women allow people to
give them too much because they're not
going to say no to a gift which is fair
enough
um but just recognize that your a
betting the culture of simping so if you
want something different if you want to
receive something different if you want
to receive more respect then you need to
respect yourself and only take what you
want to receive
um which will actually be what you want
so it's my final thoughts cool I mean my
final thought is thank you everyone for
being with me because I've been like
I've had a cold
I'm doing like the whole man flu thing
I'm really like
crazy right now I'm drugged up and all
kinds of stuff but essentially
if you have watched
two or more of our videos and you have
not subscribed and we have what pal beef
what do we have beef that's right and um
also go and follow me on Sarah Garvey
follow me on all social medias this man
do a hundred get me to 100K please okay
I'm sick have some sympathy for a guy
okay guys um a couple announcements
before we end the show the first being
we have two clips channels so make sure
you go subscribe to both that is just
pearly clips and pearl daily
um we have two different editors on the
account so you just get different types
of Clips
um on top of that guys make sure you're
a part of our memberships so you can
join our live chat during the show I'm
into five the five dollar tier it's the
price of a cup of coffee a month
um unless you be a part of the live chat
the second gets is the Ten Dollar tier
you get to be a part of our Discord and
our behind the scenes Vlogs the third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and the fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
some people use this to help grow their
you YouTube other people want to know
questions about the show questions about
life I don't know but sign up for that
if you want to talk to me also guys go
follow my Instagram um it's just pearly
things one I'm trying to build it back
up
because they took away my old one
and it was so bogus because she insulted
me first and then I insult back and then
now I'm the bad guy and I take
majestic creatures
I can't I've been told to stop using
that word no but they are majestic
creatures though I'm just saying if
you're gonna beat 300 pounds you
shouldn't call me ugly I'm just saying
there's a lot to there's a lot to insult
I'm telling you is what it is you you
started the anyways it doesn't matter
because I got my Instagram taken
um and go follow my fifth and sixth Tick
Tock it's just pearly things dot five
and six make sure you follow both so in
case they take away the fifth one I am
on account warning right now so then we
have the sixth one as backup if you want
to be a part of the show I don't know if
we've added it to the chat yet but look
up the pregame show Instagram on
um on Instagram just put in the pregame
show it should come up like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and thank you to Edgar Rays I also saw
your um your Super Chat he's a 50 super
chats thank you where all these
donations are going towards um blessings
camera thingy I forgot what it's called
but like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel we'll talk to
you next time